who has access to what
this seemingly simple question is at the
core of the principle of least privilege
and it's a difficult one to answer
access reviews and security audits are
time consuming and painful for
administrators especially considering
permissions granted through policy
inheritance from an organization policy
to an individual project
this is where policy analyzer comes in
policy analyzer is a policy intelligence
tool that queries your iam policies
across your organization folders and
sub-project resources to provide you
with access visibility and support
access administration and audit and
compliance related tasks
it does this by using query templates
templates that you can use as a jump off
point for your own queries
with the right queries you can determine
a lot about your ian policies like which
principles can access a resource
which principles have certain roles or
permissions assigned to them
what kind of access a particular
principal has on a resource
which particular resources can a
principal access
and any conditional access that may be
configured
policy analyzer provides you with a
number of pre-configured templates based
on customer demand and common queries
each query template is made up of two
parts
the scope and up to 12 parameters the
scope is simply whether you want to run
the query on an entire organization one
of its folders and its projects or an
individual project
the parameters will indicate what
principle role resources or permissions
to analyze
let's walk through filling out a query
template to find out what principles are
able to view or delete a cloud storage
bucket that i have in my project under
iam and admin you'll find policy
analyzer
right away you'll be presented with a
few query templates
we can create a template or choose one
that helps us answer the question what
principles are able to access my cloud
storage bucket
this one who can delete gcs buckets is
close so we can start there
up top is a scope
in this case i want to limit my query to
this particular project
since this is a template a parameter is
already filled out
as is this query will look for any
principles with the storage bucket
delete permission
i also want to know who can modify the
contents of the bucket so i'll add the
storage object viewer role as a
parameter
and since right now i only care about
one particular bucket i will include it
here as a resource in parameter 3.
now let's run this query and see the
results
up here is a recap of the query scope
and parameters
and the results are down here
according to these results these three
service accounts
have permission to delete the storage
bucket
through these roles
assigned on the project policy
meanwhile this user account has a
storage object viewer role granted
through the resource in policy a detail
you would not see by just looking at the
project i am policy
the easy visibility into your iem policy
that policy analyzer provides is a game
changer when it comes to making sure
that you're delegating appropriate
amounts of access for the resources in
your project it's an especially useful
way to maintain compliance and ensure a
secure in policy across all projects and
resources in your organization
to learn more about policy analyzer and
other tools that make up google cloud's
policy intelligence check out
cloud.google.com
policy intelligence
you